so this could be the last time I ever
see the castle because g2a we're
supposed to complete today but due to a
technicality we might not be able to
complete so right now this is probably
the hardest most stressful property
purchase has ever happened
so babies today I'll give you the
lowdown on the castle we're very very
stressed right now I mean I'm not as
stressed as of one might be in this
stressful situation but I'm still
stressed what's happened is we bought
the castle
we agreed to buy four eight eight eight
hundred thousand pounds which is all
fourth grade we've got about four
hundred thousand pounds cash in our bank
that we can put down and when we went to
the property the other idea was that we
kept rooting for the remaining four
hundred thousand pounds and we spoke to
a lot of people and based on the
property and and what the donut value of
the property was gonna be and all that
kind of stuff it was very you know very
obvious that we would get bridging no
problem as long as we sorted out the
Japanese knotweed and we you know got
quotes and things like that
so we spoke to our bridging guy and he
said yeah you know you'll be able to get
booking for absolutely no problem four
hundred thousand pound for you and put
you foot down four hundred thousand by
yourself
boom you're complete at the end of the
month and all be okay so we were like
right so we're waiting on the bridge in
finance and we haven't had a definite
confirmation that we've completed now
we're due to complete on the 31st of May
and we're waiting in it and we'll weigh
in and the bridging finance combo just
stringing us along right yeah yeah yeah
it's all okay yeah and I'm getting
worked up man I'm saying you know can we
have but the money ready to go can we
have some kind of defin a 100%
confirmation that we can have Emily goes
with you to complete to getting sooner
and sooner and sooner and they can't
just stringing us along and me Russell
get a bit stressed out
but we're being assured by our broker
the money well cram don't worry all this
con stuff anyway today is the day that
we're supposed to complete and we have
another money we have another budget and
would you to complete today and all over
and got my broker yesterday obviously
not particularly happy and he then said
she totally changed the goal posts and
said oh their lender has now said that
they need the quote to be to be done by
enchanted surveyor and it has to be
someone who's got experience with
heritage properties and this and this
and this which we haven't got which is
going to take us like a week at least to
sort out and then there's no guarantee
that 100% get it anyway and and now we
just like what the heck so we're we're
now on the way to go to the property and
we're gonna speak to we've arranged for
some Chartered Surveyors to come out
there the power we should have arranged
and we're going to square it and come
out I'm going to success say can you get
started straightaway it's gonna take
days but we're just gonna have to pay
them through the nose and just get them
to start straightaway but what I'm
really trying to do and this is gonna
this this will solve all our problems
now we could raise the four hundred
thousand pounds ourself but that's hard
at this your notes is trying to raise
four hundred thousand pounds in like a
day is not easy so what I'm gonna try
and do now is I'm going to try and I've
got a meeting with the actual owner of
the castle and I'm gonna see
Inga's cross big Thomas is very own
Harley but I'm gonna see if I can
negotiate with him use my negotiation
skills oh goodness
and see if I can if we can pay half now
and then the remaining balance down the
line like in six twelve months time with
interest of course if we can do that
we've solved all our problems we can we
can we can get silly I'll get started on
the works if he says no he could say
today no
I'm not doing that you need to complete
today and then I think we'd have 10 days
grace so we'd have 10 days to then get
to get the all the quotes from the
surveyors we're low on the bridging
finance to come in and all that but if
right now I'm not feeling confident to
that where that would happen if he says
no I'm feeling like this could even fall
through and I am worried I said to us so
what the chances do you think it's going
to go through now and he said I'm
thinking about 5050 5050 is not good
we've promised the man we're gonna pull
it off him and we store the building and
he you know if we've made that was made
outward we've put down 80,000 pounds
plus feeds which will lose
we've been on TV and everything talking
about what we're gonna do which will
just be you know an embarrassment so oh
I'm right now I am feeling stressed
tomorrow I've got a crash course so you
know I'm trying to sort all this out and
then tomorrow I've got a crash I've got
a drive to London later to do a crash
course so I don't think it gets much
more stressful mess
[Music]
I think it'd be really good to restore
this building back to its original look
and feel and then bring it to a
contemporary youth today someone's going
to surround himself with the best advice
and that's the best way to be guided
through this whole process because
there's a big project as no bones about
that is definitely a big project plenty
of challenges here but so far though we
only actually been here ourselves an
hour today we've looked at things in the
you know the background with Samuel and
as yet we haven't seen anything that's
an insurmountable problem neither to us
that means an opportunity even if they
extend we're talking ten days which they
might not be able to we weren't in time
we're not getting when we're not gonna
be able to complain time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay the owner was just arrived so this
is make or break right now depending on
this conversation goes if he says yes
and work with us it's gonna save
everything if he says no we're gonna be
very screwed so I'll let you know how
get on if you don't hear back from me
it's probably bad
[Music]